As a member of a class, an object can be
associated with variables and constants.
Variables and constants that
are associated with a particular class
are known as properties.
We're going to talk about
three types of properties.
Stored properties, type properties,
and computed properties.
Let's start with stored properties.
In Swift, there's a strong
emphasis on immutability.
So you'll see a lot more properties
defined as constants than in
other languages.
Let's talk about how those
constants are initialized.
Stored properties must be set when
an instance of a class is initialized.
Here we're setting
the title director and
release year to strings being
passed into the init method.
In this case the parameters have
the same name as the properties.
To distinguish the properties
from the parameters,
you can use self to represent
the object being initialized.
Initialization would look like this.
To call the initializer instead
of using the name init,
we use the name of the class.
And then if we want to access
the properties that we just set,
we use dot syntax.
So that's the name of the object.the
name of the property and here
in the sidebar we can see that the title
of Thursday night movie is Point Break.
Notice that I 've used
external parameter names here,
external parameter names
are required for init methods.
There is another option for
setting an object stored properties.
You can give them a default value, off
course in this case that wouldn't work
out so well because the director
property is a constant.
So it can't be changed.
But let's say we were only interested
in movies directed by Rob Reiner.
We could set the default value of
director in the property definition and
then not bother setting
it in our init-method.